[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESCO CARUCCI:
My name is Francesco.
I'm a game developer advocate.
Really, I'm a game developer.
I've been making games
since 1999, give or take.
I'm a graphics engineer.
So I'm super excited
to talk about Vulkan.
It's graphics APIs.
I'm a geek, and
it's going to show.
I worked on several engines
in my gaming career on--
who has ever played
"Fable II" here?
She did.
Yep, that's my work.
It's my engine with others.
And I also work on
CRYENGINE from Crytek,
the "does it run on
crysis" thinking.
I'm a geek about graphics APIs.
And today I'm super excited
to share this stage with two
titans of the Vulkan ecosystem.
Here with me, Tom and Jung-woo.
They will show you what is
tools and best practices
to bring to life console
quality experiences
on mobile, which
is unprecedented.
We're going to talk about
the Vulkan system, which
is a big ecosystem.
And Tom will go in
great details about it.
And then we're going to talk
about tools, because I mean,
really, an ecosystem
is as good as the tools
that you can run on.
If you remember back in the
day, the Xbox 360 and the PS 3,
times the PS 3 had
arguably better hardware.
But the games on 360 were
probably looking better
for a long time because
of the amazing tools
that were running
on the platform.
I'm super biased, because
I worked on the 360.
But someone working
on PS 3 will tell you
that their tools
were amazing too.
That's why they could
make fantastic games.
So we're going to explore
tools on running on Vulkan.
And now what the user tool for?
Oh, use tools for
improving game performance.
And Jung-woo will show you
how you can use these tools
and you can use best
practices to literally make
games sing using Vulkan.
And then we are not
going to have Q&A.
I don't know why it's there.
But you can come afterwards.
So let's come talk to me.
Here's the thing.
I am here standing on the
shoulders of these titans
to tell you that Vulkan
is viable on Android.
It's been a bumpy road.
There are issues.
We know.
But I personally worked
on games that either ship
Vulkan only or shipped
with Vulkan render that
are making games.
And they're making money.
Vulkan is viable.
And we're going to
go to great lengths
to show you how and why.
One of the
characteristics of Vulkan
is, well, the driver
overhead is much lower
compared to OpenGL,
which basically means
that things like state
validation in OpenGL
happens all the time.
Like, you are submitting a draw
call, and the driver's like,
are the states correct?
Yeah, they are.
Submitting another draw call--
but are they really correct?
Yes, they are.
You checked right a second ago.
In Vulkan, it's something
that you do once.
You cache.
You build your state pipeline.
And off it goes.
You render as many draw calls
as you like with that pipeline.
And it's immutable.
It doesn't need to be
verified every time.
This means lower driver
overhead, lower CPU
consumption, lower CPU usage,
a lower power consumption,
simple consumption.
I mean, you can use CPUs
as much as you like.
Which is, for me, one
of the main reasons
to start thinking about Vulkan.
Your CPU will be
engaged reasonably less
than with a standard
OpenGL render, which
means that you're
going to give more
chances to the various course
to go to sleep and consume
less power.
Which also means
that you're going
to have less chances go
into thermal throttling.
I talked yesterday about it
too for about 20 minutes.
Lower power consumption
means longer battery life,
which means more
money in your pockets.
Also, Vulkan has been
designed from the ground
up from the beginning to be
a multi-threaded API, which
means that you can build your
common buffers in parallel
on several threads.
You're not stuck
anymore into this world
where all your comments are
serialized into one thread,
and then off they go to the GPU.
Now, you can take full advantage
of the multi-core architecture
that we now run our phones on.
Again, multi-thread API means
shorter render frame times,
also means more chances for the
various cores to go to sleep,
less battery consumption, again.
And here is what I like
the most about Vulkan.
The fact that I'm a
graphics engineer--
I write this engine.
I know when the
shuttle buffer happens.
various render targets
I'm rendering to need
to be rendered to.
I know which texture I'm using.
I know everything
about my engine.
At least I hope so.
I can tell the
driver what resources
depends on what resources.
I don't need the driver to try
to figure it out every frame
from what I submitting.
I am in full
control with Vulkan.
And with control comes
great responsibility.
There is a higher
chance to get it wrong.
And Tom will show you
how to detect these cases
and do something about it.
This is the latest
CRYENGINE demo
that was featuring ray tracing.
It's a Vulkan demo.
It looks stunning.
And it runs on mobile
without the ray tracing part.
But this thing runs on mobile.
It was running on my Pixel 3.
This video is coming
from my Pixel 3.
It's a direct capture.
They posted this in
two or three weeks.
Can you play it?
Thanks.
I strongly encourage
you to come over there
and see it running on device.
This is unheard of.
Special thanks to
[INAUDIBLE] and Vladimir who
put up this demo in no time.
I was amazed to
seeing it running.
And now it's time for Tom.
Thank you.
TOM OLSON: Thanks, Fran.
So first, to correct all the
things he said that are wrong.
We're not going to
go into deep detail
about debugging tools
or the ecosystem,
because we only have 20 minutes.
And it's a big thing.
And so what we're going to do
is take a very high level view
of just a little bit of it.
And then I'll go into great
detail on a few things
that I think are exciting.
I'm kind of assuming that Vulkan
is not new to most of you.
You kind of know the
basic principles.
And at least some
of you are probably
more skilled than I
am, because by the way,
I should say he's
a game developer.
I'm not.
Never have been.
Sorry about that.
So as to who I
am-- my name's Tom.
I work for ARM on
the Mollie GPU team.
And I also chair the
Vulkan working group.
So I have two hats
with me today.
I'm going to talk from
both perspectives.
I will try to be clear about
when I'm talking about what.
So 10,000-foot view--
I tried to draw a picture.
And the conclusion
was it is complicated.
I don't mean that in the
creepy social media sense.
I mean that there are
a lot of moving parts.
I work mostly in the
red stuff over there
with the specifications,
conformance, validation.
But there is a whole army
of people working, including
your friendly neighborhood
dev techs, at least one
of whom you'll
recognize on the right.
So the point of
this slide is not
to say that it's complicated.
It's to say that there's a lot
of people, a lot of software
teams, working very hard
across the ecosystem
to make Vulkan a good platform.
The whole ecosystem
is much bigger
than it looks from the outside.
What this slide doesn't
show is the growth
that's been happening.
I tried to draw a
picture of that.
It was a total non-starter.
What I'll show instead is
just a few quick slices
through the data to
give you some sense.
So one thing I track
is SDK downloads.
I don't actually have the data
for Android, I'm sorry to say,
because their SDK is bundled.
But for the Vulkan
SDK for desktop,
this is what we're seeing.
It's noisy, but the
growth is continuous.
I also like to track what's
happening in open source.
Monday night, I went to
GitHub and typed Vulkan
at the very top
level search box.
It told me there were 3,126
projects that mentioned Vulkan.
I've been doing that
for three years.
And I can plot the data.
And it's as clean as a whistle.
It's either linear, or
the second derivative
might be slightly positive.
But the rate of growth there
is very impressive as well.
One of the things that my
committee worries about most
is making sure that you have
quality drivers to develop on.
So when we write
specs, we also write
conformance tests
in as much detail
as we can afford to to make
sure that implementations
that say they implement
the spec actually do.
So we launched three years
ago with 100,000 test cases
in conformance.
We're at 400,000 today.
And you can do the math.
Again, it's pretty linear.
So we expect this to
continue indefinitely.
We know it's working
because every time we
add tests the GPU vendors
come back and say, oops.
And then they go off and
they have work to do.
So that's a good thing,
from my point of view.
Finally, of course,
there is content.
It was kind of a slow ramp
in mobile reflecting the fact
that it took Vulkan
a while to build up
a substantial footprint
in the market.
Last year was the year
when Vulkan really
became a thing on desktop.
This year it's really
a thing on Android.
So a lot of very high
quality stuff shipping.
That's all the detail you get
on the ecosystem as a whole.
Sorry.
That's all I have time for.
What I would like
to do is zoom in
from 10,000 feet
to 10 inches, talk
about a very narrow advance
in the tools ecosystem
that I'm really excited
about and looking forward
to seeing people use.
It's called
GPU-assisted validation.
The work was done by
LunarG with funding
from Valve and in consultation
with the Working Group.
They're both members.
And we all go way back.
I should say all of this part of
the talk is with my Vulkan hat
on, talking for the
Working Group, not for ARM.
So hopefully you know
how validation works.
When your application
calls a Vulkan entry point,
it's going through an
ICD table and reaching
a hardware-specific,
GPU-specific driver underneath.
And that ICD is doing
no error checking at all
if it can help it.
It assumes you're using
the API correctly.
If you're not,
something will happen.
But it's not the
driver's problem.
So that's one of the reasons, as
Fran said, that the drivers are
very efficient, very fast.
But it's a hellish
debugging environment.
So to make debugging and
development possible,
we provide validation layers.
So you can tell
the loader when it
initializes the ICD interface
to insert validation underneath.
Then when you call into
those entry points,
the validation
layer checks them,
tells you if you're doing
something wrong before it
passes the data to the ICD.
This works great for
things like invalid enum.
It works for things like I'm
passing in shader code, which I
hope you know how SPIR-V works.
If it declares a
SPIR-V capability
that your hardware
doesn't support,
it can catch that kind of error.
Those are all static errors.
Unfortunately, most of the
interesting errors are dynamic.
So for example, you
might have a GLSL shader
that starts out declaring an
array of 6 texture samplers.
And if in your code you
reference one of those,
and you reference outside the
array, that's a static error.
SPIR-V validation will catch it.
But actually, the compiler--
GLS glslang-- will
catch it first.
So you will fix it,
and you'll be fine.
But if your code is
doing something dynamic,
if the index is coming
from a shader stage
input or a buffer or a
texture, the compiler
can't do anything on your host.
So what's going to happen if
you actually execute this code
and that index is out
of range, the spec says,
you get undefined behavior.
If you're lucky, what that
means is it draws your geometry.
And there's a texture
corrupt or missing.
And you can look at the
picture and figure it out.
But honestly, you're
usually not that lucky.
Usually you either get
"device lost," or you just
get something totally weird.
And you just have no
clue what's going on.
And it takes you days and days
and days to figure it out.
So now we have something better.
This is as of JDC.
Again, we've made
progress even since then.
The way this works--
your application wants
to make a shader.
It loads in a SPIR-V blob.
That's the binary
intermediate shading language.
It passes it to
CreateShaderModule.
If you have this validation
enabled, the shim--
that is the validation
layer implementation--
grabs the blob, runs
it through spirv-opt,
which is a general purpose
shader transformation engine.
And that spirv-opt in
this mode goes through,
finds all the references to
texture descriptor arrays,
and sticks in extra SPIR-V
code around them to check
is it in range or not.
If it's not, write
an error log message,
and also coerce
it to be legal so
that hopefully you
won't get "device lost,"
at least not right away.
So that gets passed back, goes
down into the native driver,
and the whole schmear
gets compiled.
When you eventually run
a command buffer that
does this, that
contains this code,
after the buffer completes,
validation checks the log
and sees if there's
something there.
If there is, it writes you
a human readable message.
So it's a lot of text.
But there is a lot
of information here.
So it tells you, for example,
what's the name of the error.
They're supposed to
have error ID codes.
Sorry, we didn't get
around to that yet.
It tells you the details.
You indexed out of
range exactly like this.
It gives you the handle of the
command buffer, which is OK.
But mapping it to your
code is kind of awkward.
So fortunately there's
a debug extension
called ext debug utils.
You can use that to give
symbolic names to your objects.
And if you've done
that, the log message
will include the symbolic
name of the object
as well as the handle.
It tells you which draw call,
in this case, the first one.
It gives you pointers
to other objects
involved-- the pipeline state
object and the fragment shader.
It tells you the
invocation as best it can.
So in the case of
a fragment shader,
it gives you the frag coord
where this error occurred.
Often you can look at the scene
and see what was being drawn
or infer things
about it from that.
It gives you the index of
the xspirv instruction.
In order to actually
use that, you
have to run the spirv
disassembler or on your blob
and read through
it, jump to line 116
and see what was
happening there.
It's not the easiest thing
in the world to figure out.
Fortunately, as part
of this project,
we also added debug support--
that is dash g support to GL
slang, the shader compiler.
So if you're in this situation
and you debug dash gs,
this log message will
include the file name where
your error occurred,
the line number,
and it'll print out the source
line, which is way cool.
It's almost like
debugging a real computer.
A few things to note--
there are version dependencies.
There is a performance
cost that is
going to perturb the time course
behavior of your application.
The two most important things--
it needs a free
descriptor binding slot.
If you're working on
an implementation that
only has a few, and
you're using them all,
it's not going to work.
We have a fix for
that in flight.
It's not here yet.
The other thing is that
currently it only checks image
and texture descriptor arrays.
But that's just us
driving the golden spike.
Obviously, this is extensible
to all kinds of things.
And in fact, we've already
landed partial support
for the EXT descriptor
indexing extension-- a.k.a.
Bindless.
So if you were
waiting for that, you
know Bindless is kind
of narsty to debug.
We have a fix for you coming.
So more information available.
Thanks again to LunarG.
So switching to my other hat.
You all saw the hats.
Well, I can take it off.
All right.
So like most GPU vendors, we
have a developer support team
based in Cambridge, UK, but
with outposts around the world.
And their mission is to
help you use Vulkan well,
use it efficiently,
particularly on Mollie.
But most of what helps on
Mollie helps everywhere.
So making Vulkan great
is part of their mission.
And they do that typically
first by one-to-one interactions
with you.
If you file a support issue
at MollieDeveloper.com,
they're the guys who answer
you and work with you.
That doesn't scale well.
So they also do blog posts.
They do sample code,
tutorials, et cetera.
That scales.
But it is hard to
build intuition.
You have to read it over
and over and talk to people.
It's kind of annoying.
So in hopes of making
that situation better,
what we released
at GDC this year
is a toolkit we call the
Vulkan Best Practices Toolkit.
This bundles
together tutorials--
sorry, it's sample
code that shows you
things we think
you should do, also
shows you things we
think you should not do.
So we have that together
with text tutorials
that walk through it and
explain the whys and wherefores.
But then the thing that's
new, and I think novel,
is that there's also
a plug-in framework
that all of these samples plug
into so that you can experiment
with them, toggle the
recommended and non-recommended
practices on and off, and see
how that affects performance.
So if you look at
it in this case,
this is a sample that looks at
load store ops at the beginning
and end of--
you know, what you do
with a frame buffer
at the beginning and
end of a render pass.
And it lets you just toggle
between different options
for the depth and
the color attachment.
But important to note--
the scene in the background
is totally boring.
Can we play that again?
The scene in the
background is boring,
but that's configurable.
All the source code is there.
You can load different scenes.
You can add your own.
There's a GLTF importer.
You can put your
own objects in it.
So you can try all
sorts of things.
You can change the shaders and
see all sorts of things happen
and experiment with it.
Thanks.
The other thing to note is
that it's multiplatform.
It is not Mollie-specific.
Some of the performance counters
that print out at the top
are Mollie-specific.
But you can run this
code on a Adreno device.
And you'll see what happens
in the case of demos
that have a frame rate as
their principal metric.
You can see differences between
how Mollie reacts to something
and how Adreno reacts to it.
And that's by design.
We want you to have
that information.
Other things to say about this--
also included in the
project are guides to using
our more advanced
development tools, which
I'll talk about in a minute.
As I said, it's all on GitHub.
It's all free.
And we're working on
trying to share this code
base with other GPU vendors
in the Android space
so that we give you a
better basis for exploring
the performance quirks
but different GPUs.
And tune your code--
in other words, don't
always take our advice.
It might be bad on another GPU.
You need to make that
trade-off, and we
want you to have the
information to let you do that.
So the last thing
I'll talk about
is what I call the power tools.
These are the tools
that our support team
uses if you call in with a
problem they can't figure out.
And you send them
code, and they have
to sit down or sit down
next to you and explore it.
There's two.
Graphics analyzer is one.
This used to be called
Mollie Graphics Debugger.
And it used to be
Mollie-specific.
It no longer is.
To be quite honest, it's
very similar to Render Doc.
If you're using RenderDoc
today and you like it,
you may not need this.
The only thing it has
that RenderDoc doesn't is
it's more aware of the
performance counters
that Mollie exposes.
We're hoping to add that
capability to RenderDoc.
So it's a good tool.
We use it all the time.
But it's not something
that you necessarily
should go and download unless
you're working with Mollie
a lot and having trouble.
The tool I do recommend
that everybody check out
is Streamline.
This is the total ARM
ecosystem performance analyzer,
which gives you sort of
sys trace like traces
of what's happening on all
the CPU cores, processes, et
cetera.
It also does that for all
the GPU cores if it's Mollie.
And it also allows your code
to inject events and put
little flags into the code so
you know exactly where to look.
It's really quite awesome.
There were two things
about these two tools
that used to really
bother game developers
and that kept a lot of
people from using them.
And they kept telling
us, we can't use it.
Those things were--
it cost money,
and you had to route the
phone you were running on
in order to have access to
the performance counters.
So I'm very pleased to
say as of GDC-ish, there's
now a starter edition,
which is free.
So you can try it, kick the
tires, see how you like it.
And the other thing,
with some caveats--
you no longer have
to route the device.
That is assuming that
the device is written
according to our guidelines.
We're working with our partners
to get them to do that.
Some are quick to do it.
Some are slower.
If you have companies
like Samsung
that are very dedicated to
providing a good developer
experience, they are
very quick to adopt.
So S9 is supported.
S10 will be supported
in about two months.
There are some things we
have to fix on our side that
are keeping it from working.
We have a list online.
You can go and see what's there.
So there's links, which I
hope you can find online.
And with that, I'll turn
it over to Jung-woo,
my good buddy from Samsung.
Sorry, man.
JUNG-WOO KIM: Thank you, Tom.
Hi.
I'm Jung-woo Kim, leading GPU
and game dev at Samsung Mobile.
I will share a book on
optimism and practices
from our partner collaboration.
Before jumping to that, I hope
to give you some introduction
first.
The game is so
important for Samsung
because what we
really care is not
just device, but also
use experience that
comes from the device.
The high def game is one of
the most serious and hardest
to achieve user
experience on mobile.
Because in mobile, everything
is limited by form factor.
The fundamental
performance difference
between PC and mobile
is come from different
of the thumbnail design, power
budget, and battery capacity
within this form
factor limitation.
And even we keep chasing
peak performance.
It is not something you can
keep using for sustainable
workers like gaming.
Because of this, optimization
is so important in mobile
than any other area.
Not for the trade
optimization between quality
and performance, but for
the real optimization
for great performance
within even higher fidelity.
The new technology to break
through the fundamental problem
are essential, like Vulkan
64-bit multi-thread rendering
are those.
We believe Vulkan is the
most demand a new technology
to achieve this.
So we're heavily focused on
Vulkan for recent four years.
To accelerate
adoption of Vulkan,
we realize that making many
best practices with real market
games are required.
But game developers
are always busy.
So we are announced the
Galaxy GameDev at 2016,
Samsung new game
developer support for web,
and helping Android game
ecosystem with adoption
of new technologies.
These are our key partners.
And you can see both big players
and also the indie developers.
You can see both the
unity and UE4 developers
at the same time.
The multiple in-house game
engine developers too.
They were taking the risk
of bringing new technology
into their game development
and always aiming
a higher goal and
quality and performance.
I want to say thank
you to all partners
to give us a great
chance to work with them.
The game that team
has around the 30 game
dev engineers from five
different locations.
They work hard, sometimes
on-site the partner developers
studio, sometimes also remote
support at their offices.
And also hope to say thank
you to the team for your
all contribution to show
bright future of Android gaming
ecosystem.
During a collaboration
with the game developers,
we learned a lot.
There are four key areas of
game optimization we think--
about tools and
SDK, Google and GPU
vendor like [INAUDIBLE],, as
Francesco and Tom already
mentioned.
So now I focus more
on the other areas.
GPU driver, the game engine,
and developer support--
all these three are not perfect
at this moment in Android.
That's true.
The first, GPU driver--
the quality and performance
both are two main requirements
from Android game developers.
We are working tightly with
the GPU vendor [INAUDIBLE]
for optimizing GPU driver.
This is the graph of the
GPU frame time of heavy GPU
seen in "Fortnite."
It took around 29
milliseconds in March.
But now it reduced
to 22 milliseconds
in November with
the same model GPU.
Average frame gain is around 5%,
just with the driver software
optimization.
Improving quality of a GPU
driver takes a longer time.
So for accelerating
the process of this
we are working with Google to
enhance the updatability of GPU
driver in Android.
This will bring better way of
updating GPU driver by play
installation, and hope to
ship this feature as soon
as possible to help both game
developers and also end users.
Even with better quality and
performance of GPU driver,
game engine is also
one of the big area
to make Vulkan support well
for the real game development.
Unity has something great
to support all the Vulkan
community developers at 2017,
and now multiple Unity games
support Vulkan and show
real performance benefit.
"Final Fantasy XV Pocket
Edition" is one of those.
We had a forum on on-site camp
at Okinawa for the screenings
and Summertime Studio.
We did many Vulkan optimization
on Unity pending render.
And finally we got 42 to the 60
frames per second performance
gain.
One of the main
optimization we made
was about pipeline barriers.
Let's talk more about
the pipeline barriers.
We pick up the heavy
vertex job example
to show impact level using
wrong pipeline barrier setting.
This Vulkan sample is
showing the serialized vertex
and fragment job during GPU
processing with DS5 streamline
capture.
So performance is
not that good--
62 milliseconds GPU frame time.
A pipeline barrier created
an execution dependency
between the two
active pipelines.
Execution of the
current round path
will wait at the
destination stage
until the execution of
the former random pass
has completed its source stage.
And considering the narrow
down to the two render passes--
example, shadow and main,
with the Naive Case main
always wait until completion
of all pipeline stages
in the shadow render path.
All [INAUDIBLE] fragment
job are not fully paralyzed.
And those two random cases
came at 28 milliseconds.
If we consider pipeline barriers
set more optimal in this case,
we can set beginning
of the fragment stage
for the main render
path just need
to wait until the completion
of the shadow round pass.
After changing
pipeline barriers set,
you can see shadow
and main render
pass are in the [INAUDIBLE].
And those two render
passes take last time
now-- the 22 millisecond.
We can optimize all render
passes of this simple
with same manner and
see overall frame
time reduced from
the 62-millisecond
to the 40-millisecond.
Same work load,
but take less time.
We also supported the
Tencent Timi Studio-L1
for "Honor of Kings."
Vulkan have a lot to improve
the performance of "Honor
of Kings."
And even with the S7 it showed
a big performance gain like a 41
to the 53 frames per second.
Another optimization
we made is uploading
unnecessary
load/store operation.
Each attachment of render
pass has a set operation
for load and store.
This should be carefully managed
to avoid unnecessary overhead
to road and store the attachment
between the ownership memory
and host memory.
"Hundred Soul" by Hound 13 also
gets a noticeable performance
gain by Vulkan.
And the render pass road
store optimization also
has a lot in this case too.
You all know Samsung and Epic
Games have a good relationship.
We worked together
developing Protestor demo,
and made the same agreement
to support only Vulkan UE4
developers too.
So we did many contributions
to you for Vulkan.
One of the recent
UE4 bay collaboration
was that Tencent
game for PUBG Mobile.
And we did many works about
update descriptor set.
Let's talk about
descriptor set more.
In GL, the process of
setting uniform data
is simple and readable.
But how about Vulkan case?
First, we define
how many descriptor
sets descriptor type is
needed on the pipeline
stage and allocated descriptor
set with that information.
After this it should prepare
information of uniform
buffer an image in the
WriteDescriptorSet structure.
And here we need allocated
VkBuffer for uniform data.
Now we can update
this script to set
with the calling Vk
allocate descriptor set,
and find the
descriptor set, finally
we can use the data or
image on the pipeline.
It's so complicated.
But let's forget about it.
Please just remember we
need to allocate buffer
and call Vk descriptor set.
In ideal case we should have
the static object and view
direction.
We can allocate a Vk buffer
once and update it for the set
initially and just
reuse them everlasting.
But in real cases, things are
more that dynamic we cannot
predict which object and
are generated or destroyed.
And so whenever the objects
are created or destroyed,
we need to allocate or
release the buffer every time.
And this will cause a
huge overhead in CPU.
Solution is allocating
a huge buffer
and using offset on
the buffer information
structure in the sketch, we can
abort the frequent allocation
of the VkBuffer.
But because of buffer
information structure
is a part of the Vk
WriteDescriptorSet,
so we still need to call vk
UpdateDescriptorSet every time
before binding a
descriptive set.
Better solution for avoiding
overhead of a calling update
DescriptorSets every time
is using dynamic offset
when binding DescriptorSet.
In this case, dynamic offset
when binding this could set.
I'm not-- sorry.
In this case, we can
set the offset value
on the buffer information
as 0, and we just
deliver the offset
information with a dynamic
offset in the vkCmdBind
descriptor set.
With summary, this optimization
is a multi CPU site uploading.
We could manage VK
buffer by using Offset.
We also could manage
VkUpdateDescriptor set
caused by using dynamic offset.
With this Vulkan
sample using offset
case that shows about 90
frames per second with--
and still CPU bounded--
using dynamic offset case
show the 24 frames per second.
And now less if you bound
it, but more GPU working.
Android systrace show
the 25-millisecond taking
a VkUpdateDescriptor
set is gone.
After dynamic
offset optimization,
uploading CPU have the
GPU work better and more.
Traha is a very recent work with
an accent in worldwide games.
And update disk is the set
optimization have a lot too.
And this gave a 35 to
the 56-frames per second
gained by overall Vulkan
optimization with it.
Galaxy GameDev supports
the game developers
who want to develop Hi-fi
for the Android games.
We support optimization
in games and GPU driver
for better Vulkan support
in Galaxy devices.
But from this, all we found goes
to the GPU vendor and the game
engine companies for
wider distribution.
We are also contributing to the
Android with Google and Vulkan
working group within
cronies our final goal is
improving overall Android
gaming ecosystem better.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]